so there are uh a number of stories
related to 2020 voter fraud that we will
be covering tomorrow
and i have one for today and uh
the the story is still all about
voter fraud for the 2020 election you
might be thinking
wow david it's almost june they must be
talking about voter fraud in some local
election that was last month
no they're still talking about recounts
audits voting machines
about the november 2020 election okay
zachary petrizo from salon
has a wild twitter thread which outlines
how my pillow ceo and trump crony mike
lindell
claims to have physically obtained
dominion and smartmatic voting machines
apparently used in the 2020 election
he claims to commit fraud in that
election
and is hiding the machines around the
country
almost like some weird geocaching check
out this complete
absurdity zachary patrizo writing quote
my pillow ceo mike lindell is now
claiming
he has not only obtained both dominion
and smartmatic voting machines
but also has hidden the machines in
secret locations around the country
okay so that's already bonkers off the
wall stuff
goes on to say quote according to a mike
lindell assistant who just spoke with
salon
the pillow maven is currently flying
somewhere now
and is unable to comment on the matter
then it gets even wilder
saying that quote according to public
information i can confirm that lindell
is now flying aboard his private jet
tail number
n497sp which took off from
new bedford massachusetts and appears to
be heading west at this time
unclear if he is traveling with a voting
machine
they actually have the receipts from the
flights finding out that quote lindell
made a very quick stop at elmira corning
airport in horse heads new york
and is now on his way back to bedford
new bedford massachusetts
remains unclear if a machine is riding
in hor hiding in horse heads
and why it was such a fast trip this is
almost like a bizarre
backwards scavenger hunt of some kind
how much of this new nonsense of lindell
flying around
claiming to have voting machines how
much of this is going to come out in the
civil suit against mike lindell
by dominion voting systems by the way if
he did obtain voting machines who did he
get him from
if you get an extra firm my pillow
pillow
and it's a bit too firm maybe there's a
voting machine
in there i received an email from a
viewer saying
david don't you realize what's going on
this is mike lindell
starting to lay the groundwork for an
insanity defense
no no no no no lindell is a narcissist
like trump
they don't think they can get caught
they don't believe they will get in
trouble
could this be the explanation for the
recent ufo uap
stuff that's been much discussed could
it be mike lindell
launching voting machines around the
skies no
i don't believe so will they ever be
done and satisfied
with the 2020 election and the voting
machine stuff
probably not probably not but this is
the latest mike lindell
reportedly now has voting machines
in his possession really wild times we
live in
really wild and depressing one of our
sponsors today is
covid rescue fund covid rescue fund
is helping small business owners who
have lost
their businesses during covid there are
over 100
000 small businesses that have had to
close their doors
since the pandemic began there are many
organizations out there
helping businesses who are still open to
stay afloat
but covet rescue fund is one of the few
organizations working to help businesses
reopen who have had to close covet
rescue fund
crowdsources funds to provide grants up
to one hundred thousand dollars
for these owners to create new
businesses
i would implore anyone in my audience to
help covet rescue fund in their mission
by donating at covidrescufund.org
all money that you give is going to the
mission
not to compensating people who work for
the organization
the founders of covid rescue fund are
big fans of the david pakman show
let's help them bring back as many small
businesses as we can
the link is right underneath this video